[Musik]
das wasser
hat feuer
minute
ernsthaft
herzlich willkommen zur sense weg heute
machen was ganz ganz cooles und zwar ich
koche ticker trends nach ja kennen sie
wahrscheinlich an habt ihr schon mal um
mal anders gesehen tik tok ist so eine
plattform wo ganz ganz junge menschen
unterwegs sind auch meine kinder unter
anderem gla die samira und es gibt viele
plattformen zwischen also ich komme aus
einer zeit da gab es myspace ich weiß
nicht ob ich das überhaupt noch kennt
danke wer kennt wen und das kennt heute
keiner mehr und dann gab es noch studivz
auch verschwunden und die einzigen
plattformen die sich eigentlich
durchgesetzt haben sie sind eine youtube
facebook instagram ja und jetzt
natürlich tick tack tick tock ist eine
chinesische plattform meistens kommen
sie aus amerika die plattform und diese
plattform ist jetzt nicht unbedingt
unumstritten aber welche plattform ist
es schon aber diese plattform dieses
trends ich bin nicht auf kicker
unterwegs weil ich noch ein normales
leben habe und nicht überall sein muss
meine frau die ist auf tik tok hat auch
schon ein riesen fangemeinde und tik tok
setzt extreme trends das ist echt der
wahnsinn
und ich mache jetzt mal ein paar ideen
für euch und ich brauchte eine kleine
hilfe will alleine schaffe ich nicht und
ich habe hier wirklich an tik tok
experten dieser tv experte kind alle
trends auf tik tok so und jetzt holen
wir sie es ist nämlich die ella
ella
so
wichtig
sagt ja was schauen sondern liebsten auf
tik tok
die muslim aufmachen
[Musik]
und das fruchtfleisch auch ob und was er
macht man für mehrere clans
yakult ja genau ok du hilfst du jetzt
mal die tik tok experte ist und jetzt
machen wir was machen wir heute machen
ja drei trends oder ist der erste weil
wir ein bisschen hunger und hier sind
lauter sachen die du sagst okay und
deswegen kann es erst 113 rezepte fangen
wir an mit big fate pasta
[Musik]
geht es hier irgendwas was du nicht
magst was
knoblauch mag es nicht
also sein hielt stimmen mal ganz kurz
und für unser weg passt da brauchen wir
nicht ganz ganz einfache zutaten die
haben im normalfall alle zu hause und
zwar brauchen wir 250 gramm nudeln je
nachdem man kann spaghetti nehmen man
kann nehmen was man möchte dann brauchen
wir 200 gramm väter eine mozzarella am
besten den büffel mozzarella dann haben
wir ungefähr 200 gramm cocktailtomaten
olivenöl sechs esslöffel thymian 1
teelöffel dann haben wir hier an
teelöffel oregano 2 knoblauchzehen und
setzt eine große knoblauch dann haben
wir noch salz und pfeffer nach belieben
also ich fange man tut es mal da rein
[Musik]
perfekt
so
wir sind nicht so glücklich bin die mama
genau und den schneiden wir ein bisschen
heller okay
ja der ist voll fluffy wir sind dann so
ausdrücken diese optik dann hören flachi
was heißt eigentlich du sagst ja ab und
zu mal dass ich genug bin was ist nun
was ist es
okay also papa ist ein anfänger dann
nehmen wir den basilikum hat bringt
übrigens vergessen reicht euch einen
kleinen zweig so also abtropfen und
reinwerfen okay nicht in spielen ja
jetzt an basilikum drin was ich
vergessen habe den ofen vor zu heizen
auf 175 grad umluft
hier einfach für die heißluft will sich
umluft 175 grad sagt und stand
dann einfach die tomaten reim machen tut
immer schön verteilt
und ihr könnt hier einfach eine ganz
normale auf vornehme oder so hier bord
so wie wir es auch haben so eine glasbau
so jetzt haben die tomaten drin und
jetzt olivenöl ok
ok wartet bis das zur seite genau
die genau das ist
ja wohl
olivenöl könne sogar einmal mehr möchte
olivenöl gibt es nicht genug ok
ok schatz reicht vielleicht recht was
dann machen wir den primären einschätzen
auch ein bisschen zur teil komplett okay
genau wie oregano auch bisschen
verteilen schatzwechsel das
gefällt mir
ja aber schön verteilen okay
übrigens das rezept ist ungefähr
für uns zwei reichte locker
jetzt machen wir das rein machst du
einen nicht so mancher schatz glaubt mir
schmeckt richtig lecker termin und zwar
knoblauch das magst du gar nicht
weiß wer knoblauch nicht mag der mag
knoblauch auch nicht
beim bier
wusstest du dass
ein bisschen salz
so ein bisschen knoblauch chili
knoblauch hat wetter
genau
das war schon okay so hast du jetzt kurz
den ofen also ganz ganz easy schneller
geht es eigentlich gar nicht
wahrscheinlich geht es jetzt allein
innerhalb von vier minuten gemacht
[Musik]
ja wenn man schon paar erdbeeren und ich
muss in baku 1 25 minuten lang und dann
machen wir zwischenzeitlich auch mal die
nudel
lag bei mittlerer stufe den backofen
25 minuten einstellen bei 170 grad
so
dauer
25 minuten
perfekt
so jetzt kommt der nächste super tik tok
trend was machen wir
und was ist am pink so besonders und
so sieht es aus
[Musik]
okay da machen wie scientology da gibt's
auch eine coole geschichte dazu
genau wie sisi und da gibts ne coole
geschichte dazu uns war dieser hibiskus
sie können natürlich selber machen aber
der ist von der firma ball liegt also es
keine platzierung ihr könnt auch nestlé
nehmen denn zuerst
auf jeden fall war es wirklich so dass
dieser dieser trend so extrem war dass
überall in ganz deutschland dieser
hibiskus t ausverkauft war also sie sind
im liefer nicht mehr in der lage kommen
und die hatten 150 prozent steigerung
und es ist heute immer noch so dass
gewisse extreme momentan wirklich zum
beispiel von der firma volvic saumäßig
schwer zu bekommen ist außer heißt
erlernt und könnte einfach im
kühlschrank angreifen ok wie kann man
auch selber machen statt richtig lecker
geschmeckt im diskus t
probier mal und sei aber ehrlich ok
alles da er schmeckt lecker ist der
zucker drin 38 haben bei 100 milliliter
okay
okay jetzt machen es auch noch leckere
uns mal machen wir unsere pink pink pink
tritt ganz easy zu machen weil wir
brauchen ja ich bin
okay merck lasst eure kinder weg von tik
tok schon jetzt mal kurz die eislöwen
rein ok
ok egal schmilzt runter heller dann das
nächste
okay das mir ist auch unter es ist wie
der klimawandel schmilzt einfach und
dann geht es runter und dann haben wir
halt nach sich ziehen
dann nehmen wir den halben liter
ja aber nur die hälfte ok
job
[Musik]
doch okay ist fertig recht kann ich noch
trinken
so dann braucht ihr noch ungefähr 52
meter komisches milch oder komischen
saft oder ich weiß ich das mal so sagt
kokosnuss nicht nur probieren so problem
ob es richtig schmecken ja
wie ich es ehrlich
mit blatt ok alles klar es soll dafür
dass ein bisschen auf
[Musik]
ganz ehrlich ich finde dass das ist zwar
kokosnuss bio ich will dich cool aber
ich finde das frische kokosnuss aus der
kokon so viel besser schmeckt
ja
ok und dann könnte es eine mit erdbeeren
oder beeren oder oder himbeeren alle das
ist zuhause haben noch gar nie genau
so warte noch nicht fertig dann haben
wir hier
holunderblütensirup den hat die mama
schon und sauber gemacht aber das ist
okay nur ein bisschen noch ok
[Musik]
jetzt kommt zum moment der wahrheit
jetzt kommt aber merken dass fünf jahre
alles
so muss jetzt trinken und essen zusammen
mit
der lange schmerzlich
ok
bildung ist ein luftholen okay so hat
sie wirklich geschmeckt also ich fand
ich vollgas jetzt durch die ganze
kombination schmeckt irgendwie alles
nach litschis
haben auch gleich lietz ins glas werden
können oder
warum das öfters waren okay aber dass da
so jetz ma lin dritten
genau und zwar machen wir die pancakes
genau und so sieht es übrigens auch
ticker auf dieser trend
[Musik]
und dafür braucht ihr
225 gramm geschmolzene butter
150 gramm butter milch 30 gramm zucker
dann brauchen wir noch eine prise salz
und 125 gramm back mail
freising mehr da ist jetzt schon
backpulver drin wildes minute es nicht
habt dann könnt ihr auch einfach noch
zwar normales 405 weizenmehl nehmen und
dann noch mal und
dann noch mal einen halben teelöffel
backpulver reingeben okay dann gehen wir
das eingereicht ja
komm schnell schnell schnell schnell
schnell sagt dann nehmen wir die
geschmolzene butter
dann nehmen und muttermilch
sie ja wohl ganz kurzer zickzack dann
den zucker
so und jetzt sowas verrühren
jawohl und das backen von mama
ok und rühren und rühren
[Musik]
so jetzt früher
wir produzieren zu machen wir deine
mutter so auf jeden fall tun wir jetzt
noch ein bisschen meinl extrakt rein in
einen schuss
stop
polizei nahm zwei möglichkeiten und zwar
man kann jetzt einen spritzbeutel nehmen
und die ganze masse in einen
spritzbeutel reinmachen oder
wir haben hier eine dose flasche okay da
können die zwei machen schatz
gibt mir die flasche schatz ich mache
das hielt bis kurz
sollen die durch die flasche
[Musik]
sie hat noch was ich hab doch was
mag doch ein bisschen habe ich noch
und immer schön auskratzen ganz wichtig
ist es wichtig so jetzt haben wir alles
hier drin und jetzt kann ich diesmal
sprühen ok
wack trend spricht oder an öl nehmen
noch in die pfanne nicht unbedingt eine
beschichtete pfanne kurz ein bisschen
rein
genau
das reizt so etwas banken versprechen
ist auch ein ganz normales kokos
rational gemischt oder ihr nehmt
was ihr wollt so jetzt sind die flasche
immer noch so kleine punkte machen bei
stelle ist wenn der mini paket pantic
[Musik]
da bist es nur machen schatz ich zeige
es einmal ganz okay da hab ich jetzt mal
ganz kurz
und das macht so ein bisschen falsch
aber ich nicht schlimm
so erst mal hoch heinzen okay
so und dann einfach so drauf und gar
nichts machen gemacht
sagt akin ja
das macht es aber nicht allein okay das
macht nur wenn der papa da ist ok weil
er hier ganz frauen geworden nein
nein da monstern immer man kann es
besser als ich ihn ja du kannst du
kannst gleich gut
so
sollten die nächsten coups
[Musik]
so jetzt mal hier noch den rest
fertigkeller dann haben wir ganz ganz
viele okay
sagt
ehlers so
mini pancake sind jetzt fertig und jetzt
wollen wir unser auflauf okay
okay okay wow das sieht richtig cool aus
auch von easy peasy gemacht richtig
das heißt es auch
jetzt sind wir raus die mini pancakes
sind hier dann immer unsere nudeln und
weil die nudeln einfach gekochte nudeln
erhielt jetzt meiner meinung nach
spaghetti bären cooler gewesen aber wir
hatten keine mehr
es soll es mal die nudeln da rein und
es wirklich 250 g/t naturschutzes
bisschen vermischen
[Musik]
so
schmeckt
was ich noch nicht gut da ehrlich
schmeckt gut
deutsch sein fleisch gegessen als nicht
okay jetzt machen so einen teller und
manchmal auch zu machen dann immer noch
ahornsirup und
den machen wir nicht
so jetzt machen wir es auch einen teller
traum und das was wir zusammen gemacht
haben beispiel das probieren lassen die
mama liebe mag kommst du mal
so wir haben jetzt tik tok trends
gemacht ganz ganz ganz in diesem jahr
und jetzt da das ist eine gabe schatz
habt ihr auch das getan
wir waren näher aber wir machen keine
tipptopp kannst trends wir machen nur
food
habe auto und
ich probiere es darf aber
sei
aber sinnvoll ehrlich also wenn noch
etwas fehlt dann thomas hinzuschauen
noch sagen können es ja noch reinmachen
ein bisschen salz baby gebe ich dir
recht
achtung dadurch dass mit dem ofen
gebacken daneben nicht oben gebacken die
haben also rein gemischt
ja es ist dann erwartet
hier hat die ausgebacken
auf dem bock in der pfanne
aber ich glaube ihr hättet die nudeln
auch im ofen mit backen können
mit samira schon macht doch mal einfach
noch wasser ein fünftel in ruhe und dann
alles okay wir haben ist einfach so
gemacht also das getränk
[Musik]
das nennt sich wie nennt sich das
und hibiskus und dann noch
holundersirup umsonst zucker und gar
nicht
so
aber coach noch immer und
ja wir gucken die top trends am vortag
umstellt
und sage bescheid auf welchen
plattformen seien die unterwegs auf tik
tok instagram youtube facebook ja auch
manchmal schaut euch das video momentan
auch auf youtube aber was ist eure der
it plattform
wir haben den leuten schon erklärt was
das intelligent ist noch interessant
dass die dümmsten aufs netz sind und ich
glaube das schreibt keiner mehr snapshot
wahrscheinlich die kritischen 19 auf
facebook und die älteste ist die älteste
auf facebook ja okay vielleicht haben
auch noch myspace wer kennt wen dann
schreibt video studivz
alles klar vielen dank beim zuschauen
und wir sehen uns demnächst wieder mal
wenn die ella dann 22 ist machs gut
er durchs sagen könnte abschied sich
immer
ja kommt mal bist du kannst 23 ja
[Musik]